uh what are ways to improve ligo in the
future increase the sensitivity
i've seen a few ideas that are kind of
fascinating
is are you interested in them
sort of looking i'm not speaking about
five years perhaps you could speak to
the next five years but also the next
hundred years
yeah so let me let me talk to both the
instrument and the science okay
so that's they go hand in hand i mean
the thing that i said is if we make it
better
we see more kinds of weaker objects and
we do astronomy okay
we're very motivated to make a new
instrument
which will be a big step the next step
like making a new kind of telescope or
something
and
the ideas of what that instrument should
be uh
haven't converged yet there's different
ideas in europe they've done more work
to kind of uh
develop the ideas
but they're different from ours and we
have ideas
so
but i think over the next few years
we'll develop those
the idea is to make an instrument that's
at least 10 times better than what we
have
what we can do with this instrument 10
times better than that
10 times better means you can look 10
times further out
10 times further out is a thousand times
more volume so you're seeing much much
more of the universe
the big change
is
that if you can see far out you far you
see further back in history yeah you're
traveling back in time
yeah and so we can start to do what we
call cosmology instead of a astronomy or
astrophysics
cosmology is really the study of the
evolution of the
oh interesting yeah and uh so then you
can start to hope to get to the
uh important problems having to do with
uh
how
the universe began how it evolved and so
forth which we really only study now
with
optical
instruments or
electromagnetic waves
and early in the universe those were
blocked because
basically it wasn't transparent so the
photons couldn't get out
when everything was too dense what do
you think sorry on this tangent what do
you think an understanding of
gravitational waves from earlier in the
universe can help us understand about
the big bang and all that stuff yeah
that's that's so but it's a non
it's a it's a
it's another perspective on the thing is
is there some insights you think could
be revealed just to
help a layman understand sure first we
don't understand we use the word big
bang we don't understand the physics of
what the big bang itself was
so i think
my my
and in the early stage there were
particles
and there was a huge amount of gravity
and mass being made
and so
uh
the big
the so i'll say two things one is
how did it all start how did it happen
i'll give you at least one example that
we don't understand
what we should understand
we don't know why we're here
yes
no we do not
i don't mean it philosophically
i mean in terms of physics okay
now what do i mean by that if i go into
my laboratory at cern or somewhere and i
collide particles together put energy
together i make as much anti-matter as
matter right
antimatter then annihilates matter and
makes energy so
in the early universe there you made
somehow
somehow
a lot of matter and antimatter but there
was an asymmetry somehow there was more
matter and anti-matter
that matter and anti-matter annihilated
each other at least that's what we think
and there was matt only matter left over
and we live in a universe that we see
that's all matter
we don't have any idea we have an ideas
but we don't have any
we don't have any way to understand that
at the present time with the physics
that we know
ask a dumb question does
antimatter
have anything like a gravitational field
to uh send signals
so
how how does this asymmetry of a matter
anti-matter
could be investigated or further
understood by observing gravitational
fields or weirdnesses and gravitational
fields i i think that
in principle if there were you know
um
anti-neutron stars instead of just
neutron stars we would see
different kind of signals but
it didn't get to that it's we live in a
universe that we've done enough looking
because we don't see anti-pro matter
anti-protons anywhere no matter what we
look at that it's all made out of matter
there is no antimatter except we go in
our laboratories
so
but when we go in our laboratories we
make as much antimatter as matter so
there's something about the early
universe that made this
asymmetry so we can't even explain why
we're here that's what i meant yeah
physic physics-wise not you know
uh not in terms of
how we evolved and all that kind of
stuff so uh so there might be inklings
of uh
of some of the physics that uh
gravitational so so gravitational waves
don't get obstructed like light so i
said light only goes to 3000 years so it
goes back to the beginning so if you
could study the early universe with
gravitational waves we can't do that yet
then
it took 400 years to be able to do that
with
optical but
then you can really understand the very
maybe understand the very early universe
so in terms of uh
questions like
why we're here or what the big bang was
we should be we can in principle study
that with gravitational waves so to keep
moving in this direction it's a unique
kind of uh way
to understand our universe do you think
there's more nobel prize level ideas to
be discovered in relation to
i'd be shocked if their gravitational
waves if there isn't uh not even going
to that which is a very long range
problem but
i think that uh
we only
see
with electromagnetic waves four percent
of what's out there
there must be
we looked for things that we knew should
be there
there should be
i would be shocked if there wasn't
physics objects science
and with gravity that doesn't show up in
everything we do with telescopes so
i think we're just
limited by not having powerful enough
instruments yet to do this
do you have a preference i keep seeing
this uh
e-lisa idea
yeah
is it
do you have a preference for
earthbound or space fairing
mechanisms for they're complementary
it's a little bit of a signal it's a
it's completely analogous to what's been
done in astronomy right so astronomy
from the time of galileo
was done with uh visible light
yeah
a strong the big advances in astronomy
in the last 50 years or because we have
instruments that look at the infrared
microwave
ultraviolet and so forth so
looking at different wavelengths has
been important basically going into
space
means that we'll look at instead of the
audio band which we look at as we said
on the ear surface we'll look at lower
frequencies it's so it's completely
complementary and it starts to be
looking at different frequencies just
like we do with astronomy isn't it
it seems almost incredible to me
engineering-wise just like on earth to
send something that's kilometers across
into uh into space is that is it harder
to engineer
then it actually is a little different
it's three satellites
separated by hundreds of thousands of
kilometers
and they send a laser beam from one to
the other
and uh
if they
the distance if the triangle changes
shape a little bit they detect that from
the acids did you say hundreds of
thousands of kilometers yeah sending
lasers to each other
[Laughter]
okay it's just engineering
uh is is possible though
yes
okay
uh that's that's just incredible because
they have to maintain i mean the
precision here is probably there there
might be some more what is it maybe
noise is a smaller problem
i guess there's no vibration to d to to
worry about like seismic stuff
so getting away from earth maybe you get
away from yeah those parts are easier
they don't have to measure it as
accurately at low frequencies
but they have
a lot of
tough engineering problems the
the
in order to detect that the
the
gravitational waves affect things the
sensors have to be what we call free
masses just like ours are isolated from
the earth they have to isolate it from
the satellite
and that's a hard problem they have to
do that pretty not as well as we have to
do it but very well and uh they've done
a test mission and
the engineering seems to be
at least in principle in hand
this will be in the 2030s 2030s yeah
this is incredible this is uh
this is this is incredible
let me ask about black holes um yeah so
what we're talking about is observing
uh
orbiting black holes
uh that i get i saw the terminology of
like binary black hole systems
is that's that's when the the one that's
when they're dancing
okay going around each other just like
the earth around the sun okay is that
weird that there's black holes going
around each other
so
finding binary systems of stars is
similar to finding binary systems of uh
black holes well they were once stars so
um
so we haven't
said what what a black hole is
physically yet yeah so what's a black
hole so
black hole is a is first it's a
mathematical concept or a physical
concept and that is
a region of space
so it's simply a region of space where
the curvature of space time meaning the
gravitational field is so strong
that nothing can get out yeah
including light
and there's light gets bent
in gravitational if the gravitations if
the space time is warped enough and so
even light gets bent around and stays in
it so that's concept of a black hole so
it's not a f
and maybe you can make maybe it's a so
that's a concept
that didn't say how they come about
and uh there could be different ways
they come about the ones that we are
seeing
uh
there's a
we're not sure
that's what we're trying to learn now is
what they but the general
expectation
is that they come
the bla these black holes happen when a
star dies
so what does that mean that a star dies
what happens
a star like our sun
basically makes heat and light by fusion
it's made of
and as it burns it burns up the hydrogen
and then the helium and then
and slowly works its way up to the
heavier and heavier elements that are in
the star
and uh when it gets up to iron the
fusion process doesn't work anymore
and so the stars die
and that happens to stars and then they
do
what's called a supernova what happens
then
is that a star is a delicate balance
between an outward pressure from fusion
and
light and burning
and an inward pressure
of gravity trying to pull the
masses together once it burns itself out
it goes
and it collapses and that's a supernova
when it collapses all the mass that was
there is in a very much smaller
space
and if a star if you do the calculations
if a star is big enough
that can create a strong enough
gravitational field to make a black hole
our sun won't
it's too small too small
and we don't know exactly
what it but it's usually thought that a
star has to be at least three times
as big as our sun
to make a black hole but that's the
physical way there you can make black
holes
that's the first um
explanation that one would give for the
for what we see
but it's not necessarily true we're not
sure yet what we see in terms of for the
origins of the black holes no the black
holes that we see
in gravitational waves so the but you're
also looking for the ones who are binary
solar systems like so they're binary
systems but they could have been made
from binary stars so there's binary
stars around so that's
right so so that's so this first
explanation is that that's what they are
gotcha um
other
explanati but but what we see
has some puzzles this is kind of the way
science works i guess yeah um
we see
heavier ones
than
up to
we've seen
one system that was 140 times the mass
of our own sun
that's not believed to be possible
with the
parent being a big star because big
stars can only be so big
or they
are unstable it's just the
the fact that they live in an
environment that makes them unstable
so
the fact that we see bigger ones they
maybe
come from something else it's possible
that they were
made in a different way by
little ones eating each other up or
maybe they were made
or maybe they came
with the big bang the prime what we call
primordial which means they're really
different they came from that we don't
know at this point if they came with a
big bang then maybe they account for
what we call dark matter or some of it
like there's a lot of them if they came
with them and yeah because there's a lot
of dark matter yeah
but uh will gravitational waves give you
any kind of
intuition about the origin of these
we think that if we see
um the distributions enough of them the
distributions of their
masses the distributions of their how
they're spinning so we can actually
measure when they're going around each
other
whether they're spinning you know like
this direction or the spin or or no the
orientation whether the whole system has
any
wobbles
what
so this is this is now okay
we're doing that and then you're
constantly kind of crawling back and
back and and we're calling back in time
and seeing how many there are as we go
back and so do they point back so you're
like what is that discipline called
cartography or something you're like
mapping
this the early universe
via the lens of gravitational
waves not yet the early universe but at
least back and forth earlier right
so
um so black holes are this
mathematical phenomenon but they come
about in different ways we have a huge
black hole
at the center of our galaxy and other
galaxies
those probably were made some other way
we don't know when the galaxies
themselves
had to do with the formation of the
galaxies we we don't really know so the
fact that we use the word black hole
the origin of black holes might be quite
different depending on
how they happen they just have to in the
end have a gravitational field that will
bend everything in
how do you feel about black holes as a
human being there's a there's this thing
that's
nearly infinitely dense can
doesn't let like light escape
isn't that kind of terrifying feels like
the stuff in nightmares i think i think
it's it's an opportunity
to to do what exactly
so uh
like the early universe is an
opportunity if i we can study the early
universe we can learn things like i told
you and here again
we have an embarrassing situation in
physics yes
we have two wonderful theories of
physics
one based on quantum mechanics
quantum field theory and
we can go to a big accelerator like at
cern and smash particles together and
almost explain anything that happens
beautifully using quantum field theory
and quantum mechanics
then we have another theory of physics
called general relativity which is what
we've been talking about most of the
time which is fantastic at describing
things at high velocities long distances
you know uh
and so forth
so
that's not the way it's supposed to be
we're trying to create a theory of
physics not two theories of physics so
we have an embarrassment that we have
two different theories of physics
people have tried to
make a unified theory what they call a
unified there you've heard those words
for decades
uh they still haven't that's been
primarily done theoretically or tried
they people actively do that
my personal belief is that the
like
much of physics we need some clues
so we need some experimental evidence so
where is there a place
if we go to cern and do those
experiments gravitational waves or
general relativity don't matter yes if
we go to study you know our black holes
particle physics doesn't matter we're
setting these huge objects so where
might we have a place where both
phenomenon have to be satisfied an
example is black holes inside black
holes yeah
so we can't do that today
but when i think of black hole it's a
potential
treasure chest
of
understanding the fundamental problems
of
physics
and maybe
can give us clues
to how we bring to the embarrassment of
having two theories of physics together
that's my own
romantic what's the worst that could
happen it's so enticing just go in and
look
do you think um
how far are we away from figuring out
the unified uh
theory of physics the theory of
everything i think what's your sense who
will
solve it like what discipline will solve
it yeah uh
i i think uh
so little
progress has been made uh
without
more experimental clues as i said that
we're not
we're just not able to
say that we're close without some clues
the best the closest
the most
popular theory these days that might
lead to that it's called string theory
yeah
the problem with string theory is it
works
it solves a lot of beautiful
mathematical problems we have in physics
and
and uh
uh it's
it's uh
very satisfying theoretically
but it has almost no predictive
maybe no predictive ability because
it is a theory that works in
11 dimensions
we live in a physical world of
three space and one time dimension
in order to make predictions
in our world with string theory you have
to somehow get rid of these other
seven dimensions
that's done mathematically by saying
they curl up on each other on scales
that are too small to affect anything
here
but how you do that and that's okay
that's an okay argument but how you do
that
is not unique
so that means if i start with that
theory and i go to our world here i
can't uniquely go to it
and if i can't
it's not predictive and that's that's
actually and that's a killer that's a
killer and string theory is it seems
like from my outsiders perspective has
lost favor over the years perhaps
because of this
it's a lack of predictive power i mean
that science has to connect to something
where you make predictions as beautiful
as it as it might be so i don't think
we're close i think we need
some
experimental clues it may be
that information
on
something we don't understand presently
at all like dark energy or
probably not dark matter but dark energy
or something might give us some
ideas but
i i don't think we're
i can't envision right now
um
in
the short term meaning you know
the horizon that we can see
how we're gonna
bring these two theories together
you